education is far less about a set of
facts than a way of thinking then
learning how to critically think and
therefore what I always think should be
the basis of Education is not answers
but questions we should teach kids how
to question now having said that of
course to be a productive adult there
are certain skills that are required
reading writing and in the old fashioned
days we used the arithmetic now we say
mathematics and we and it's important
that we provide students those basic
skills and in that sense I'm in favor of
a Common Core because I think there are
certain things that most reasonable
educators and most reasonable
mathematicians and scientists and
historians would agree are part of a
part of what every modern literate
person should should should have as a
tool to go out and look at the outside
world I am in favor of saying okay let's
get teams of educators and experts in
certain disciplines to say what are the
basic things that we think are an
essential part of an early education for
equal put them together and create as as
well as possible a set of goals and
tools to learn those things one thing I
cannot understand and people are
probably going to be upset about this is
why local school boards have control
over educational content because local
school boards are never to be made up of
individuals without any training one of
the reasons we send kids to school is to
help protect them from their parents I
mean in a good sense I mean most parents
want their kids to learn they're good
but the point is the reason kids are
outside the house is so they can do an
exposure to things that might take them
beyond the biases that they learn at
home and if we send the school we should
take them beyond the buyers biases that
are present in local school board
members I we there should be standards
that are based that are determined by
educators not by people who for one
reason or another run for election to a
school board so a common core is
something I'm in favor of what I'm not
in favor of by the way is standardized
tests however the testing always
inevitably means you teach students to
be able to do tests and and I've seen it
at all levels including by the way at
graduate school we have many grad
students say from from China who are
excellent at taking physics tests but
when they want to become researchers so
just being able to regurgitate
information is not what makes you a
creative researcher and and I think the
same is true for a for a young person
being able to know specifics of to pass
a test is not the same as being able to
understand how to go about answering
those questions